look once you tell everyone your fake
Prince is fake nobody's falling for it
again and how many times can you really
watch a cat get rescued from a tree
spoiler the answer is ten
following close behind the premiere of
The Bachelor Fox's Joe Millionaire is
one of many reality dating shows that
helped shape the popular sub-genre it
ran for two seasons with the first
season finale being the most watched
entertainment program in Fox history at
the time as reported by the New York
Times the second season titled the next
Joe Millionaire not so much the premise
is simple 20 women compete for the love
of one Bachelor The Twist they've been
fooled into believing the man is a
millionaire when in reality he's a
construction worker the idea of lying to
women to then turn around and demean
them as gold diggers brought on
well-warranted criticism towards Joe
Millionaire however criticism alone will
almost never be enough to kick a show
off the air instead it was the faulty
premise that did this one in described
as a one-time Stunt by the then fox
chief once the gig was up for Joe
Millionaire there is no more fooling
contestants or viewers the creators of
the show must have forgotten the only
way to build healthy long-lasting
relationships is with trust except not
so fast the show came back in 2022 with
its Revival titled Joe Millionaire for
richer or poorer a little tweaking to
the premise now has the show featuring
18 women dating two men not knowing
which is a millionaire and which is not
over a decade later Joe Millionaire
figured out a way to reel in viewers
without lying to its contestants
what now feels like a distant fever
dream was the 2010's fascination with
home renovation series that starred
former music Sensations like rev runs
renovation Vanilla Ice got in on the
popular Trend with his own home
renovation series The Vanilla Ice
Project it may have seemed like a
strange direction for the rapper but it
was nothing compared to what came next
and Vanilla Ice goes Amish he left the
mansions in the rear view mirror well in
a manner of speaking they don't even
have mirrors in their house as much as
viewers enjoyed seeing Vanilla Ice get
down and dirty with his handiwork the
premise of adjusting to traditional
craftsmanship and the Amish lifestyle
wasn't suited for longevity the show ran
for two seasons from October 12 2013 to
November 15 2014 including episodes
where Vanilla Ice assists a cow in
giving birth and ice is out in Amish
buggy mostly Vanilla Ice would take on
renovation projects within the Amish
community however judging by the show's
abrupt and unceremonious ending it seems
that there simply just weren't enough
Amish construction projects that needed
a vanilla makeover
Tommy Lee is the epitome of the Rockstar
lifestyle so sending him off to college
where many young people learn about real
life responsibilities is a recipe for
Peak entertainment The Motley Crew
drummer attended the University of
Nebraska not to get a degree but to
entertain viewers at home from August
16th to September 13 2005 Lee filled the
shoes of a real-life student by finding
a roommate trying out for
extracurriculars attending parties and
studying for classes
uh Tommy rad is a measure of angle in
physics however as we're all aware a
college is only temporary leaving the
show with little room to grow and ending
after a six-episode run Lee did get to
promote his second solo album Tommy Land
The Ride by using the album single good
times as the theme song for the show so
all in all not a complete flop
appealing to a similar music loving
audience VH1's bands reunited may have
bitten off more than they could chew the
premise of reuniting former musical
groups using elaborate schemes proved to
be more difficult in execution turns out
ex-band members aren't usually keen on
reunions for the sake of a reality
Show's success
question to you is are you are you up
for it no you're not oh no the show
managed to run for two seasons from 2004
to 2006 and many viewers witnessed some
of their favorite bands coming back
together to perform past hits not every
episode was a success with either one or
all band members refusing to reunite or
perform the only way to keep the show
going was to up the Antics by going for
higher profile bands their attempts to
reunite the legendary band The Smiths
resulted in their biggest failure yet
when they couldn't get the attention of
band member Morrissey it was a long shot
from the beginning but these were the
shortcomings that left them with little
to go on and there was no Encore for
bands reunited
no one could replace Cassandra Peterson
as Elvira The Late Night horror cult
movie host from the 1980s horror movie
program Elvira's movie Macabre but that
didn't stop them from trying with the
search for the next Elvira get ready for
the most shocking reality show of all
time
running for four episodes on Fox
contestants dubbed The Unlucky 13
competed in various challenges including
acting auditions a dinner date with a
reality TV star and selling Elvira
branded coffee to tourists Cassandra
Peterson was featured as a judge along
with other guest judges
wait honey can I ask you a question what
is the name of the show Matt mcabri how
about Macabre Macabre would you be
surprised to learn the Series winner did
not in fact become the next Elvira
Peterson went on to revive her character
in 2010. she returned as a horror
Hostess in 2014 with Hulu's 13 nights of
Elvira and again in 2021 for a one night
movie marathon on shutter titled
Elvira's 40th anniversary very scary
very special special suffice it to say
there was no real search for a new
Elvira making this series one and done
with a single season
this controversy-ridden reality dating
show had a short-lived premise from the
beginning a group of men and women
battle it out for a chance at romance
with social media personality Tila
Tequila the two groups are unaware of
each other and Tila's bisexuality until
the final two contestants are chosen can
you think of anything more romantic
I am attracted to each of you all for
very different reasons
in Theory the show featured by
representation in mainstream media at a
time when it was severely lacking
however tabloids broadcasted their
speculations about Tila's true sexuality
and intentions in 2007 a source close to
the show claimed Tila has and has had a
boyfriend for over a year and she's not
really bi Tila denied the allegations at
the time but later seemingly confirmed
the claims in a now removed 2018 YouTube
video according to the Hollywood
Reporter the reality series was MTV's
second highest rated series premiere in
2007 but season two didn't live up to
its season 1 success a shot at love with
Tila Tequila proves that it's difficult
to keep a reality dating show running
when your main love interest is rumored
to already be in a relationship and
shows no interest in her chosen winner
foreign
way out of my league but for who I'm
pretending to be it's perfect it takes a
special kind of someone to genuinely mix
up Matthew Hicks with Prince Harry yet
the show I Want to Marry Harry managed
to fool 12 contestants into thinking
they were competing for a shot at love
with the real Prince and I Want to Marry
Harry really went to extremes to keep
the lie alive winner Kimberly Birch
recounted some of the producers
elaborate stunts in an interview with
Splinter saying they actually had a
therapist come on set at one point and
talk to a few of us who were saying it
wasn't him we found out later that it
wasn't a real licensed therapist it was
just someone from the production team in
the same vein as Joe Millionaire once
the show aired there is no chance of
fooling another set of contestants or
audiences for season two in fact
according to deadline the series was
pulled from schedule halfway through
season one dumping the rest of the
episodes onto Fox on Demand and other
services
the highly popular MTV reality series
following the lives of a group of
good-looking sun-kissed teens from
Laguna Beach High School Laguna Beach
the real Orange County was left with few
options for continuing the series Once
the original cast graduated by season 3
the entire cast had been replaced this
didn't work out as far as ratings were
concerned viewers grew connected to the
characters through watching their love
triangles drama and the usual stressors
of senior year play out am I supposed to
be really happy to see you or something
that's not what I'm saying in it was
never going to be the same with a new
group of students unless of course you
attempt a spin-off premiering in 2007
Newport Harbor the real Orange County
followed the same format however the
show unsurprisingly failed to live up to
the success of Laguna Beach the real
Orange County
from 2003 to 2012 Mike Rowe Greystar TV
screens with the most filthy disgusting
occupations that go underappreciated in
our society by featuring them on Dirty
Jobs
sassy
how did that cow crap on me three feet
away with his eagerness to get in the
mix and try these jobs out himself Rose
spotlighted the skills and tenacity of
essential workers from all around the
country airing for more than 170
episodes it was just a matter of time
before the list of dirty jobs waned thin
and sent the series into a permanent
Hiatus as micro described it in a 2012
guest column on HuffPost
and I've personally done some things to
turkeys and sheep that I'm not
comfortable talking about
Hollywood's obsession with reboots has
made way for the 2022 Revival of Dirty
Jobs after a 10-year Hiatus host micro
admitted to TV Insider the challenge now
is not to get dirty and work hard the
challenge is to apply it to jobs that we
haven't done after all you don't just
let a five-time Emmy nominated series
end without a spin-off or Revival in
this case Discovery did both with these
spin-off Dirty Jobs road trip and the
2022 Revival of Dirty Jobs
not all reality shows that have run out
of things to do are complete failures in
fact animal planets River Monsters ran
for nine successful Seasons however
after years of catching the most vicious
Predators lurking in our freshwater and
saltwater Rivers host Jeremy Wade
revealed in a press release some shows
can run forever but our subject matter
is finite ten years ago I had a list in
my head which seemed impossibly
ambitious at the time but everything has
now been ticked off and then some Guided
by biologists and extreme angler Jeremy
Wade the series took viewers around the
globe to explore fearsome creatures
living in the depths of rivers and lakes
both thrilling and educational Wade's
episodic quests would consist of
catching the fish in question and
teaching viewers about the Misunderstood
specimen fans were disappointed to see
the show go and surely Executives were
even more so after losing one of their
best performing shows a reality TV
series dedicated to saving cats stuck in
trees what could possibly get repetitive
about a premise like that airing for a
total of 10 episodes in 2015 Sean Sears
and Tom Otto of canopy cat rescue took
their rescue efforts to Hollywood with
their Animal Planet reality show titled
Treetop cat rescue now instead of
exclusively watching cat videos on
Facebook viewers could tune in to half
hour long episodes starring our favorite
felines in sticky situations according
to the Seattle Times after the premiere
of the show The non-profit rescue team
went from saving 250 cats a year to
upwards of 750. the sweet relief of
witnessing distressed Strays and Missing
Pets meet a happy ending seemingly would
have lasted years on end but upping the
ante for television wasn't a viable
option for this serious team of cat
Rescuers unfortunately one season was
all it took to scratch out all the cat
rescue related ideas and since there's
been no Revival of this particular
series we can only assume it's off the
air forever
foreign